boeing de la têt w a été abattu par un
missile de la marine américaine affirme
le journaliste pierre salinger démenti à
washington le premier ministre alain
juppé attaqué par sa propre majorité
défendu par le président de la
république qui lui renouvelle toute sa
confiance à travail égal salaire égal la
cour de cassation donne raison à une
secrétaire de direction qui se plaignait
d'être moins payés qu'une de ses
collègues la drogue en prison un rapport
officiel indique que ce phénomène prend
des proportions inquiétantes
madame monsieur bonsoir pierre salinger
est un journaliste américain bien connu
en france puisqu'il a été par le passé
porte parole du président kennedy la
firme aujourd'hui disposer d'un document
précis qui lui permet d'affirmer que le
boeing de la tbw à qui a explosé au mois
de juillet en plein vol après son
décollage de new york a bel et bien été
touché accidentellement par un missile
de la marine américaine
thierry curtet pierre salinger
détient-il un secret d'état
ils affirment qu'un homme travaillant
pour les services secrets il très proche
de l' us navy lui a remis le document
qui explique l'explosion du boeing de la
twr y avait un test mais chez eux par un
avis américains qui font des tests dans
cette région peut être quatre cinq fois
par an ils avaient dans leur a dit que
tous les avions qui passait à l'étrave
intermiel pied mais l'avion de tva était
à 13 me au pied pourquoi parce que odh
en haut de sa et avait un autre avion
qui descendait pour aller à providence
providence c'est une ville en août cette
carte
le twr part de new york vole à 4000
mètres d'altitude
car au dessus de lui à 7000 mètres
toujours selon pierre salinger va se
poser un vol du sr en fait le document
de pierre salinger circule sur internet
depuis la fin du mois d'août nous
l'avons retrouvé ce serait le même homme
qui l'aurait fait circuler sur le réseau
avant de le confier au journaliste
américain le dossier localise un navire
et un hélicoptère des gardes-côtes
mais aussi un croiseur et un sous-marin
et surtout un avion de l'us navy
le croiseur et le sous marin sont à 300
km l'avion militaire lui se serait
retrouvé à la verticale de l'explosion
en fait ils auraient été chargés de
guide
un missile dans un espace en théorie
vide l' us navy et le fbi est dément
totalement cette théorie du côté des
familles françaises
on est surpris de ces révélations aussi
fracassante que tardive la validité des
documents reste à voir puisque nous
détenons détenant des informations très
récentes des enquêteurs on est en
contact très souvent hier soir même je
les ai parlé au téléphone et ils m'ont
confirmé qu'ils sont déjà récupéré 98 et
qu'il y a aucune trace d'explosion par
missiles ou vendent et pour qui une
trace d'éléments qui puisse leur a
indiqué qu'il irait missiles quelque
part des doutes donc la justice
française va entendre très rapidement
pierre salinger
reste un autre élément troublant la date
de ses déclarations elle tourne trois
jours après les élections américaines
elle ne serait donc plus gênante pour le
candidat bill clinton et à washington un
porte parole de la marine américaine a
démenti catégoriquement les affirmations
de pierre salinger tout en indiquant que
l'enquêté continue et que toutes les
éventualités continue d'être examinée
washington philippe gassot les
déclarations de pierre salinger n'ont
pas provoqué des causes états unis mais
simplement le démenti de la marine
américaine us navy n'a procédé à aucun
tir au moment de l'explosion du boeing
le 17 juillet dernier c'est une vieille
théorie a ajouté un responsable de la
marine
on sait que le navire you ss normandie
se trouvait à plus de 300 kilomètres du
lieu de l'accident pour les enquêteurs
du fbi à et du ntsb national
transportation safety board
depuis le début de l' enquête trois
hypothèses demeurent l'accident
l'attentât où le missile
actuellement près de 95% des débris de
l'appareil ont été remontés quand la
totalité du boeing aura été reconstituée
et si aucune preuve matérielle nouvelle
née remontait la catastrophe du 747 de
la tbw à sera attribuée à l'explosion
accidentelle du réservoir central
la théorie du missile avancée par pierre
salinger ne semble pas du tout
d'actualité
d'ailleurs le ntsb
l'enquêteur donneront leur réponse cet
après midi aux journalistes américains
dans une conférence de presse
oui en ce moment même les responsables
du fbi à ils sont en train de tenir une
conférence de presse est le porte parole
du département de la justice indique à
propos de l'explosion du boeing de la
twr et bien pour l'instant les
enquêteurs
les enquêteurs ne savent toujours pas ce
qui s'est réellement passé au mois de
juillet relié au décollage de nuit j'ai
dit vous indique encore qu'un boeing 727
nigérian s'est écrasé aujourd'hui à une
centaine de km de lagos il y avait cent
quarante et une personnes à bord l'épave
vient seulement d'être repérés en france
l' affaire a pour cadre une ligne du rer
de la région parisienne il y a deux
semaines maintenant une femme policier
qui rentrait chez elle a été agressée en
pleine journée puis violée par cinq
hommes qui ont ensuite pris la fuite des
syndicats de policiers ont réagi
aujourd'hui très vivement à cette
agression dans la mesure où les
représentants des forces de l'ordre sont
de plus en plus régulièrement attaquée
en dehors et dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions agnès vahramian jean-françois
c'était dans l'après-midi du 25 octobre
entre 14 et 15 heures
ligne c du rer le fonctionnaire une
femme de 28 ans monte dans le train pour
rejoindre son domicile en congé pour
quelques jours le policier a pris soin
de laisser son arme au commissariat
seule dans le wagon
la jeune femme est habillé en civil
lorsque quatre jeunes gens s'approchent
d'elle est devenu son entrée
l'intérieur du wagon du rer et ont pris
le sac de ce fonctionnaire et quand ils
se sont aperçus que le sac contenait
uniforme ils ont découvert également la
carte de réquisition et là ils se sont
acharnés sur de cette loi fait en
exerçant des violences pour la violence
et en abaissant en la taille est dans de
beaux coups de cutter en arrivant chez
elle la jeune femme n'ose rien dire en
bretagne ses parents l'attendent et
s'inquiètent
quatre jours plus tard les voisins
alertés trouveront le gardien de la paix
prostré dans son appartement dans le
wagon aucun personnel de la sncf n'ait
été prise sur la banlieue que nous
gérons sur paris montparnasse et la
ligne c du rer
nous avons plus de 1000 trains par jour
il est absolument impossible d'avoir du
monde dans chaque voiture de chaque
train les enquêteurs recherchent
activement un témoin un homme qui aurait
assisté à la scène sans porter secours
aux policiers la jeune femme a décrit
ses agresseurs il aurait entre 16 et 19
ans violence encore à fréjus dans le
département du var à un adolescent de 16
ans a été grièvement blessé hier d'une
balle dans la tête tirée par l'un de ses
camarades le tireur a été placé en garde
à vue a priori il s'agit d'un accident
yasmina farber didier bon c'est la
question un minimum de correction de la
vie on ne leur apprendre les dangers de
la vie et à partir de là que l'éducation
prenne éventuellement le relais n'avait
rien de rien avec le plus
on ne peut pas demander à l'éducation
aux éducateurs d'un énorme établissez un
nouveau chéri
conversation animée devant le collège
andré léotard à fréjus les parents
n'arrivent pas à accepter qu'un élève et
était en possession d'une arme
le jeu a mal tourné à quelques mètres de
l'établissement devant un abribus
un adolescent était en train de montrer
un 22 long rifle à son camarade cédric
15 ans le coup est parti
accidentellement pour le blessé à la
tête
cette année-là gentil doux qui nous a
jamais posé de problème les chez nous
depuis pas mal d'années toute sa famille
est passé chez nous et à aucun moment
nous n'avons vu à 10 ont essuyé un
problème de tous quelle que nature que
ce soit ni violence en irak est née
bagarre particulière l'adolescent avait
trouvé larmes dans l'appartement de son
grand-père un problème d'éducation à
nouveau dénoncé par les familles même si
c'est un accident cet enfant là n'aurait
jamais dû avoir une arme sont mes tables
rondes responsabilisera pas les familles
le phénomène signerait s'amplifiera le
collégien a obtenu les munitions d'un
autre camarade paniqué après l'accident
il a demandé à un ami de cacher son arme
les trois jeunes gens étaient déférés au
parquet des mineurs de toulon quant à
cédric il reste en observation dans un
service de neurochirurgie à marseille
c'en était jugé stationnaire dans ce
collège flambant neufs sans problème
particulier
les cours se sont arrêtés ce matin par
solidarité puis encore cet après midi à
antony dans les hauts-de-seine
adolescent de 16 ans a blessé l'un de
ses camarades avec un pistolet à air
comprimé selon la police l'adolescent
jalousait son camarade parce qu'il était
plus fort que lui et possédait une belle
casquette c'est le visage dissimulé par
une cagoule qui l'attiré avant de
prendre la fuite pour être rattrapé
quelques instants plus tard par les
policiers du sommet franco-britannique
de bordeaux entre messieurs jacques
chirac et john major on retiendra - les
décisions de politique étrangère que la
confirmation de la confiance que le
président de la république accorde à son
premier ministre
attaqué par sa propre majorité avec pour
point culminant aujourd'hui les
déclarations de françois léotard au
figaro estimant que jacques chirac a
conscience des lacunes d'alain juppé
philippe harrouard gens connus tout au
long de ce sommet franco-britannique de
bordeaux jacques chirac a bien pris soin
de montrer par vous
toute l'attention qu'il était aux côtés
de son 1er mai alors que les critiques
fusent critiques plus ou moins sévères
de gaullistes comme charles pasqua ses
gains ce matin ces gens lui devrait qui
est monté au créneau
je crois que devoir de tous les veaux
liste de tous les français c'est de
soutenir alain juppé de soutenir le
gouvernement parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre politique mais à bordeaux comme
ailleurs sont arrivés comme un coup de
tonnerre les propos de françois léotard
se disant convaincu que jacques chirac
allait se séparer de son premier
ministre le président de la république
n'a pas attendu pour répondre cet après
midi fustigeant les déclarations
grincheuse il a été clair et net je fais
toute confiance à la lucidité et au
cours des biens courage du premier
ministre mais aussi du gouvernement de
la majorité et de tous les français ont
mené à bien cet effort difficile celui
d'inviter aujourd'hui notamment dans une
majorité qui ont sauté réaction du
gouvernement mais qui vivent tout
l'occasion au sein du parlement
la solidarité est un véritable devoir
moral et le faux plis et sourire d'alain
juppé tout cela a quelque peu bouleversé
la fin du sommet franco britannique qui
s'est bien déroulée ici à bordeaux 2
points signaler la vache folle les
britanniques dont poursuivent leur
programme d'abattage comme prévu le
zaïre paris et londres sont d'accord
pour dire que l'envoi d'une force
multinationale dépend du feu vert des
nations unies et des africains
il faut surtout que la mission soit
précise ce qui n'est pas le cas pour
l'instant
alors vous l'avez entendu pour ce qui
concerne une éventuelle intervention
internationale au zaïre l'ombre est
d'accord sur le principe reste à définir
les conditions sur le terrain maintenant
arriver aujourd'hui du médiateur
international canadien à kigali la
capitale du rwanda
isabelle des chemins
dans sa besace d'envoyé spécial des
nations unies raymond chrétien avait
surtout des réserves de bonne volonté et
de persuasion
son but convaincre le rwanda et par
extension les rebelles zaïrois de souche
tutsi d'accepter de l'humanitaire qui
aurait un volet militaire
la présence d'une force neutre sur
l'intérêt dans un objectif strictement
humanitaires sans aucune sans aucun
objectif militaire ou paramilitaire
j'ai indiqué que la france la belgique
que le rwanda où devraient s'abstenir
d'envoyer des troupes tout
pendant ce temps dans son ministère le
chef militaire rwandais refuse toujours
de reconnaître l'implication de son
armée dans les troubles à l'est du zaïre
nous sommes impliqués dans la mesure où
nous avons des réfugiés là bas c'est
bien sûr parce que des zaïrois sont
persécutés à cause de leur origine
rwandaise
voilà notre application higgins in
roanne est-ce que vous aider les
rebelles
non non nous n'en voyons nos soldats a
nulle part
la solution n'est donc pas encore trouvé
bien que l'aide humanitaire arrive
massivement dans la région une aide pré
positionné comme disent les logisticiens
impuissant on meurt on souffre on attend
on se désespère à quelques centaines de
kilomètres au delà des combats qui ont
repris
nous en sommes nous n'avons pas la
possibilité de faire passer quoi que ce
soit de la frontière mais si on nous
demande nous y sommes bien sûr disposer
de ça mais cette petite fille
pourra-t-elle attendre et les
organisations humanitaires dont nous
parlions à l'instant y compris la
croix-rouge réclament désormais une
intervention militaire au zaïre pour
permettre justement l'acheminement de
l'aide humanitaire
en direct de kigali maintenant à laurent
boussier là bas il est toujours
impossible de se rendre à la frontière à
iroise dans les camps où s'entassent les
réfugiés
mais on a tout de même laurent quelques
informations sur ce qui s'y passe en ce
moment
il a d'abord la situation militaire elle
reste assez confuse
et l'heureux élu dé combats aujourd'hui
à côté de l'immense camp de bagong à où
sont entassées six cent mille personnes
des camps des combats qui auraient même
entraîner une partie de la destruction
du camp par par le feu à goma même la
situation est assez tendue
il y aurait encore des snipers près de
l'aéroport sans qu'on sache très bien
qui tire sur qui alors au niveau
humanitaire devient la catastrophe
annoncée
hélas la situation empire chaque jour à
côté de bukavu par exemple la dysenterie
est arrivé il y aurait des cas de
malnutrition et les épidémies ont fait
leur apparition tout ça à quelques
kilomètres des des réserves des du magny
faire il ya ici dans la région
de quoi nourrir un million de personnes
pendant trois mois
à quelques kilomètres de gens qui
meurent de faim et ça c'est terrible
merci laurent pour ce témoignage à noter
encore que le secrétaire général des
nations unies monsieur boutros ghali
vient de déclarer qu'il espérait que
l'onu adopterait dans moins de 24 heures
maintenant une résolution approuvant une
intervention militaire internationale
aux high le président boris elstine
opéré du coeur il y a trois jours à
peine semble se rétablir assez
rapidement il a quitté aujourd'hui en
ambulance l'hôpital pour un autre
établissement hospitalier situé à
l'intérieur du kremlin pour autant on ne
dispose pas en in his pose pas pour
l'instant de documents réel sur l'état
de santé du président russe en france
maintenant à travail égal salaire égal
la cour de cassation en a ainsi décidé
c'est une première dans la région de
toulouse une secrétaire de direction
avait contesté son salaire dans la
mesure où celui ci était inférieur à
celui d'une de ses collègues une simple
secrétaire qui étaient mieux payés quel
laurent bailly christophe là en cas en
eau la fiche de paye de marie-christine
console secrétaire de direction 7771
francs par mois en bas celle de son ex
collègue simple secrétaire 8330 francs
par mois hors ancienneté temps qu'elle a
travaillé dans l'entreprise des longs
dans la région toulousaine
marie-christine n'a rien dit sur cette
différence pour garder son emploi mais
son contrat n'a pas été renouvelé en 92
alors elle est allée aux prud'hommes je
ne vois pas pourquoi l'heure actuelle en
1996 nous n'aurions pas
travail égal salaire égal en
l'occurrence en plus d'occuper un poste
de secrétaire de direction qui est
supposé être par rapport à des
secrétaires simple un poster supérieur
et mon coefficient était inférieure une
injustice dénoncée par les prud'hommes
dénoncée également par la cour de
cassation dans son arrêt la cour rejette
le pourvoi de l'employeur et le
contraint à dédommager marie christine
c'est une première car jusqu'ici quand
il s'agissait d'employés du même sexe la
justice laissé à l'employeur une marge
de manoeuvre pour fixer les salaires
pourtant la cour de cassation n'a fait
que rappeler la loi sur les modalités
d'application du principe à travail égal
salaire égal en tout cas cette décision
va créer bien des bouleversements qui
peut être contre aujourd'hui à travail
égal salaire égal au fond des tripes on
ne peut être que satisfait et bien
évidemment où le problème va être
beaucoup plus compliqué c'est que ceci
va carrément à l'encontre de toutes les
habitudes tout les us et coutumes qui se
sont installés dans l'entreprise et
c'est tout le principe de la
rémunération au mérite qui pourrait être
remise en cause demain si chacun scrute
à la loupe la fiche de paye du collègue
les tribunaux risque d'être encombré et
les employeurs d'entrer en résistance
alors que la contestation continue à
propos de la privatisation de thomson
multimédia à profit du coréen daewoo le
ministre du commerce extérieur yves
galland vient de se rendre à séoul où il
a pu visiter les usines de ce groupe et
notre équipe qui l'accompagnait a pu
rencontrer son président jean-paul
chapelle
christian tu
le vase est à son effigie et tout le
groupe est à son image d ou encore et 1
signifie grand univers et son président
fondateur continue de conquérir le monde
au 23e étage de l'hôtel hilton sherman
qui met chez lui à séoul
l'hôtel lui appartient son empire
industriel est présent dans tous les
secteurs
aujourd'hui il veut racheter thomson
multimédia et pour prouver qu'il aime la
france promet d'installer son siège
européen à paris c'est sur 90% sur caen
way d'ici à l'année prochaine
vous n'avez pas thompson on essaiera
quand même de s'implanter fils confiance
et sérénité chez des looks on n'ose
imaginer que thomson leur échappe les
fait beaucoup rire dont l' empire d où
le gouvernement français lui est
nettement moins à l'aise en pleine
polémique sur thomson
le ministre du commerce extérieur
transforme sa visite en exercice de
diplomatie et découvre au passage le
modèle coréen
très jeune et très disciplinés les
salariés de deus 12 heures de travail
par jour six jours sur sept et une
efficacité quasi militaire dans cette
usine est produit un véhicule par minute
la moitié pour l'exportation d ouvrir
maintenant le marché européens y compris
la france pour vendre ses produits et
s'implanter partout dans le monde
d où multiplie les promesses notamment
en matière d'emploi le ministre profite
de sa visite pour rencontrer le docteur
b le numéro 2 de déhu patron de la
partie téléviseur en rachetant de
thomson des ou annoncé la création de
5000 emplois aujourd'hui il en promet le
double j'ajoute que nous savons le
président via différents médiums que en
europe des investissements
supplémentaires seront faits le dr b ne
contredit pas en souriant il conseille
même aux journalistes de bien prendre
note encore et les promesses engage sur
tous ceux qui les écoutent
l'emploi des jeunes est un sujet de
préoccupation de toute la classe
politique française dans la mesure où le
nombre de jeunes au chômage ne cesse
d'augmenter le gouvernement dément
aujourd'hui l'étude d'un projet de loi
visant à assouplir les procédures de
licenciements en contrepartie dans
bausch par les entreprises pour autant
tout le monde donc réfléchi gouvernement
majorité et opposition syndicats
commentaires françoise laborde
oui c'est vrai que le chômage des jeunes
c'est le problème français
un jeune sur quatre est inscrit à l'anpe
soit 650 mille jeunes de moins de 25 ans
le parti socialiste a bien compris cet
enjeu qui mène l'emploi des jeunes au
coeur de son programme économique qui
sera présenté demain avec un objectif
l'embauché de 700 mille jeunes moitié
dans le public moitié dans le privé
hélas le parti socialisme par le plus
d'obligations mais d'incitations pour
les entreprises défini dans une loi
cadre au gouvernement aussi on voit bien
que les dispositifs existants sont
insuffisants et inadaptés
du coup on réfléchit à plusieurs moyens
pour lever les contraintes qui freinent
les embauches par exemple assouplir le
recours aux cdd les contrats à durée
déterminée notamment pour les petites
entreprises moins de 50 salariés
celles qui réclament le plus de
flexibilité pour pouvoir embaucher et
débaucher un député udf a présenté une
proposition de loi allant dans ce sens
et puis côté patronal c'est dit
didier pineau valencienne le patron de
schneider qui a rassemblé autour de lui
une dizaine de patrons de grandes
entreprise entreprise citoyenne qui
devrait annoncer la semaine prochaine un
dispositif très particulier l'engagement
d'accueillir jusqu'à une centaine de
milliers de jeunes dans leurs
entreprises respectives soit en
formation soit en apprentissage on le
voit donc au delà de la prise de
conscience il ya effectivement des
recherches de tous les côtés des
propositions différentes voire opposées
et qui seront sans aucun doute au coeur
du débat
dans les semaines qui viennent merci
françoise les journaux de la rue vendus
par les sans domicile fixe non plus très
bonne presse son brevet jeu de mots
après le réverbère et fin de siècle
c'est la rue qui va disparaître les
acheteurs se sont lassés de ces journaux
qui ont connu parfois quelques dérives
rédactionnelle par ailleurs le coup de
grâce a été porté par l'interdiction
faite par ratp de vendre ses journaux à
la criée dans le métro philippe
visseyrias christian hutin
aujourd'hui sur le parvis de la gare
montparnasse alain ne vend plus qu'une
dizaine de journaux par jour il ya
encore quelques mois
c'était trois fois plus pour chaque
numéro vendu 15 francs il touche 7
francs 80 depuis deux ans cette source
de revenus environ 3000 francs par mois
lui permettait de se loger et d'avoir
une vie décente
actuellement cela effectivement aux
seuls revenus je n'ai rien d'autre à
côté
alors si je n'ai pas effectivement 2
si la rue s'arrête je n'ai plus rien
pour l'instant la rue continue mais
jusqu'à d'accord le 31 octobre dernier
le journal a déposé son bilan les ventes
qui était encore de cent mille
exemplaires par mois il ya deux ans sont
tombés à 50000 aujourd'hui cette année
après fin de siècle et le réverbère la
rue et le troisième journal de ce genre
à connaître des problèmes financiers
petit à petit le grand public au départ
à lui un réflexe de solidarité a été
très désorientés par la multiplicité des
titres par les scandales qui ont affecté
les uns ou les autres de ses titres par
globalement la dégradation de l'image de
la presse de rue la rue procure travail
et protection sociale à environ 300
vendeurs elle emploie une quinzaine de
salariés et revendique un projet
rédactionnel et social sérieux
aujourd'hui c'est l'amertume je pense
qu'on n'a pas eu des moyens suffisants
et le temps suffisant pour imposer
j'allais dire
belle idée l'idée forte qu'on avait nous
ici de créer à la fois une entreprise
d'insertion une entreprise de presse
depuis quelques mois les journaux comme
la rue ne peuvent plus vendre à
l'intérieur du métro ou dans les gares
cela aussi jouer sur les ventes
aujourd'hui la rue risquent de
disparaître
le 25 novembre le tribunal de commerce
de paris décidera soit de liquider la
société soin de lui accorder un sursis
afin de trouver un plan de relanc
rapport officiel remis au ministre de la
justice indique très nettement que le
problème de la drogue est devenu un
problème majeur dans le monde carcéral
des stupéfiants sont pratiquement
disponibles dans toutes les prisons
françaises avec sa conséquence le
développement de la transmission du
virus du sida
bah les ermites joseph vaches tic la
drogue entre en prison c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui écrite noir sur blanc par
les parloirs les cours de promenade le
linge l'héroïne circulent ou plus
souvent le haschich comme ici à fresnes
nous avons
depuis le début de l'année 29-29 saisies
de produits stupéfiants à fresnes
donc effectivement je ne peux pas dire
que ça n'existe pas un rapport de
l'inspection générale des services
judiciaires la teste pour la première
fois on peut y lire par exemple que les
saisies d'héroïne et de seringue sont en
hausse et que les pratiques d'injection
sont une réalité le problème n'est pas
nouveau mais quoi faire le rapport
préconise bien sûr un renforcement des
contrôles et un meilleur suivi des
toxicomanes mais il apparaît impossible
d'empêcher totalement la drogue de
rentrer en prison
se pose alors un autre problème celui
des seringues souillées et de la
transmission du virus du sida
didier a passé onze ans de sa vie en
prison il sait bien qu'on peut s'y pique
ça distribué comme ça et il passé dans
pisa personnes et est ce que les gens
disaient qu'ils étaient séropositifs ou
c'est la prison qui devient un lieu de
mort pour ça c'est tout à fait il a nice
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas de
m et il faut arrêter avec l'idée que les
détenus ne sont pas des gens comme les
autres ou ne peuvent pas recevoir les
mêmes réponses que l'on ait déjà
commencé à mettre en place sur
l'extérieur des seringues comme les sur
angles le syndicat de la magistrature
préconise entre autres d'expérimenter la
distribution des seringues en prison
ce que pratiquent déjà l'allemagne et la
suisse mais la france ne semble pas
prête pour l'instant à le faire même si
les mesures vont bientôt être mise en
place
c'est vraiment impossible d'être sûr
qu'aucune charge ne circule à partir de
là il faut jouer la carte de la
prévention et
la carte des soins la prévention c'est
notamment l'eau de javel diluée pour
qu'il y aille minimum d'hygiène et que
si une seringue circulent à tout le
moins elle ne soit pas contaminantes la
drogue en prison tous les pays européens
ils sont confrontés
et à chaque fois deux logiques semblent
s'affronter la logique pénitentiaire et
la logique sanitaire mais de logique qui
sont condamnées de toutes façons à
trouver un terrain d'entente
un cyclone a ravagé la région côtière du
golfe du bengale en me faisant plus de
1000 victimes les vents soufflaient à
plus de 200 km heure et des pluies
diluviennes ont inondé de très
nombreuses de très nombreux villages de
cette région de l'inde
si vous passez par là c'est à dire à
l'espace eiffel à paris jusqu'à lundi
soir une idée de visite au salon
multimédia vous y verrez tout ce qui se
fait ou va se faire en matière
d'informatique d'internet d'audiovisuel
pour ne pas vous tromper dans vos achats
de demain patricia charnley philippe
chasselas la révolution du multimédia
n'a pas encore eu lieu en france
notre pays est en retard par rapport à
l'angleterre l'allemagne ou les états
unis
les femmes il tarde pas s'équiper il
faut dire que l'achat d'un ordinateur
pour la maison n'est pas simple les
modèles changent sans cesse et les prix
aussi
d'où l'intérêt d'aller à la découverte
de ce nouveau monde comme dans ce salon
où plus de 300 produits sont en libre
consultation
il allume deux hommes ont étonné je vais
tomber il ya le temps elle fait un mois
je peux faire qu'est ce que ça apporte à
vos enfants
demande ordinateur ordinateurs etc
autant il est co l'attenté
son attentisme les enfants et pas
seulement que les grands parents c'est
un phénomène nouveau s'y mettent aussi
la technologie ne les effraie pas je
trouve que c'est bien d'apprendre aux
enfants l'histoire du pays
les arts la culture enfin tout ce que
d'une façon ludique les produits
proposés sont de plus en plus
performants comme celle ventes destinées
interactive le matériel lui évolue
chaque jour
d'où cette question faut-il attendre
pour s'équiper pense que l'on va avoir
une machine multimédia dans le foyer qui
pourra peut-être faire plus que
ce que fait aujourd'hui
les coordinateurs moyens mais que cette
évolution va être
d'où s'élancent et qu'il faut déjà
rentré dans l'aventuré du multimédia
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on est intéressé pour
soi ou pour ses enfants
al'approche de noël les prix devraient
baisser
c'est une urgence dans ce domaine car le
coût de tel joujou entre 6000 et 15000
francs
reste l'obstacle numéro un
le célèbre chef d'orchestre d'origine
hongroise anobli par la reine
d'angleterre soeur solti enregistre
actuellement le don juan de mozart dans
un studio de londres pour l'occasion
le maître a décidé de se faire assister
par son élève un jeune chef d'orchestre
français âgé seulement de 24 ans louis
carzou bernard puissance
lorsqu il s'isole dans son appartement
pour répéter un passage de donjons il
n'a point l'esprit au vieux souvenirs
tels que ses débuts de musiciens dans
une harmonie à dérober
car du haut de ses 24 ans stéphane
denève a choisi de devenir chef
d'orchestre un choix nourrit de travail
mais aussi de rencontres au premier rang
desquels figure scène deux soeurs et eux
seuls qui est il m'a dit nouvelle chef
d'orchestre et dire oui très très
évidemment impressionné et il m'a dit en
donnant sa grosse partition à noter
écouter demain je voudrais que tu es
dans la phase que ça donne alors
apprenez du jeu demain et c'est ainsi
que l'accompagnateur se retrouve à
baguette en main
six mois plus tard lorsque le maestro
décide d'enregistrer donjon avec l'
orchestre symphonique de londres
stéphane est également du voyage
désormais le passage de vagues et n'est
plus l'effet magique d'une rencontre
mais bel et bien la volonté d'un mètre
de trouver la solution chez son élève
la liberté d'écrire à tous d'erhard
klein soul hip hop hop hop hop hop hop
on j'ai toujours un assistant lorsque je
conduis un opéra parce que j'aime
écouter les orchestres
depuis je veux pas juger sur le podium
c'est pour cela que j'ai besoin de
stéphane avec il m'a et 10 pour le don
juan à paris me connaît bien et puis
s'il est réellement très talentueux mais
talentueux
et
c'est absolument incroyable dans ce lieu
en plus où il ya tant de questions de
chefs temps le vite empêcheront passé
évidemment ça fait quelque chose
modestie aux allures de révérence car
bien avant l'arrivée de stéphane sort
bien seul qui lui aussi a été assistant
auprès d'affaires tascan il est le
maître soeur sol qui sera à paris le 13
novembre au théâtre des champs elysées
l'acteur chanteur américain frank
sinatra hospitalisé depuis une semaine à
los angeles officiellement pour un air
froid c'est serait en fait dans un état
alarmant c'est ce qu'on a appris ce soir
il souffrirait d'une pneumonie et de
problèmes cardiaques sérieux prix record
pour un timbre suédois a vendu aux
enchères à zurich pour deux millions et
demi de francs il devient ainsi le
timbre le plus cher du monde l'acheteur
et suédois lui aussi le timbre est de
couleur jaune alors que tous les autres
de la même série imprimé en 1855 sont de
couleur verte
sa valeur initiale était seulement de 3
schilling bonnes affaires
à l'occasion du mois de la photo hommage
à marc riboud photographe de presse il a
eu le privilège au cours de sa longue
carrière de photographier l'évolution de
la chine des années uniforme à
l'éclosion du capitalisme 40 ans de
photos qu'il expose en ce moment à pékin
jérôme bunny tristan le point
c'est à shanghai que nous avons
accompagné marc ribot armé de son
inséparable leïca d'abord il ya le
travail d' approche l'appareil caché
dans le dos hao bonjour coup d'oeil
cadrage rapide et le tour est joué
c'est un perpétuel tata demande on ne
sait pas comment ça va se passer au
surtout regarder à petit de loin comment
qui est là si ça vaut la peine de
s'approcher
c'est du blanc sur du sombre d'abord de
loin c'est vrai c'est différent de
touristes elle se détache bien les et
surtout de celle ci c'est blanc sursis
après bahreïn à une très jolie fille me
regarde du coin de l'oeil c'est alou
diarra non riboud est fidèle à la chine
depuis 40 ans il l'a vu changer du tout
au tout entre la chine maoïste de ces
premières photos en 57 et celle
d'aujourd'hui lancer dans la course à
l'argent
moi personnellement je crois que cette
vague de la région qui
gagne à une telle vitesse et qui semble
qu'au rond l'un des 10 du très jeune
très jeune
au musée des beaux-arts où il expose
c'est le photographe photographier bien
sûr il a fallu argumenter avec les
chinois pour certains clichés
ce kiosque à journaux par exemple où ce
mendiant unijambiste mais finalement
aucune ne sera censuré le public
pékinois est à la fois intéressé est
dubitatif
choc des cultures il est évident que les
sujets n'aurait pas été traités de la
même façon par un photographe chinois he
ce mineur par exemple n'a pas l'air très
motivé
les ouvriers ils ont la force pour
travailler à pau proposé cela n'ôte rien
à la popularité de l'artiste mairie vous
préfèrent les rencontres fortuites de la
rue à 73 ans il ne se lasse pas du
plaisir de voler ça et là les
instantanés de la vie
il est toujours en quête de ce qu'ils
vont devenir les personnages de ces
prochains livres de ces prochaines
expositions
je reviens à l'instant sur la sphère du
boeing de la tbw à dans une conférence
de presse qui vient de se terminer qui
continue même en ce moment les
responsables du fbi a eu des manques
donc les déclarations de pierre salinger
qui affirme qu'à nos tirs de missiles de
la marine américaine serait à l'origine
de la catastrophe
le fbi a exclu l'hypothèse d'un missile
militaire mais il ya une nuance
il n'exclut pas le tir d'un missile qui
aurait pu être tirée par un terroriste
car toutes les pièces de l'appareil a
dit le responsable du fbi annuel vieille
que vous voyez actuellement n'ont pas
été récupérés par les enquêteurs dans un
instant la météo laurent romejko
brouillard au nord soleil au sud pour ce
week-end ensuite le point route de léry
maurice 22h30 l'édition de la nuit
florence dauchez demain 7h thé ou café
catherine ceylac recevra michel plasson
directeur du capitole de toulouse et
thomas castaignède rugbyman lui aussi à
toulouse je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne je vous donne
rendez vous demain à 13 heures
bonsoir
super